[Music]
while there were of course many
negatives during
2020 one of the positives had to do with
entrepreneurship
there were more corporate formations and
new businesses starting in 2020 than
any other year according to the irs we
know some of that was
people forced into focusing on the side
hustle because they were laid off
uh some of that had to do with
people wanting to take control of their
own destiny they liked working from home
and they figured out well what's the
best way to do that
become my own boss and start my own
business travis crabtree the president
of swift filings his company helps new
businesses get started he saw a spike in
his services not only during 2020 but
one that continues through this year as
well
he says the important thing for any new
business owner to keep in mind
take care of the basics make sure to
protect yourself
talk to a lawyer he adds that his
company will take care of the compliance
issues and paperwork so you can focus on
the product